bien estamos en el problema número 10 y
por cierto tenemos un polígono que es un
pentágono justo como este que tengo aquí
ok
aquí tengo el centro de este pentágono
este es el centro de este pentágono y lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale x ahora
para obtener el valor de x quiero que
nos fijemos en triángulos a mí me gusta
más ver triángulos que ver polígonos así
que vamos a cambiar todo esto a
triángulos que triángulos bueno pues me
voy a fijar en este mundo de aquí en
este de aquí a la comparación de este de
aquí ok la comparación de este de aquí
ok comparación de este de aquí porque
porque al menos lo que sí estamos
seguros es cuánto mide este ángulo de
aquí bueno este mundo de aquí o no
cambiar de herramienta este ángulo de
aquí supongamos que se llama z le voy a
poner el nombre de z cumplen que z más z
está también se llama z más z ok
extreme edition z más z esta terminación
receta maceta esto debe de ser igual a
360 grados y todos estos ángulos son
iguales se llaman z porque estamos
hablando de un polígono regular y además
de que es un polígono regular podemos
asegurar que este este ángulo llamado el
game y estoy llamando el iev y este
llamado el 10 y este llamado james y
este llamado el ye yé yé yé yé y todos
estos son iguales y puedo asegurar eso
porque estamos hablando de un polígono
regular un pentágono lo que quiere decir
que estos ángulos son iguales y estos
sean unos iguales y es más podemos
calcular z 1 2 3 4 5 5 veces z esto
tienen que ser igual
360 grados que es una vuelta completa al
círculo y de aquí podemos decir que hace
tan es igual a 360 entre 5 lo cual es a
cuánto es 360 entre 5 dice 5 por 7 7%
los 35 aquí 35 y nos sobra uno bajo este
cero y aquí pongo un 225 los 10 y
nuestro gran cero perfecto a z debe de
valer 72 grados ok porque estoy sacando
z es decir este valor de aquí se está
vale 72 grados porque sacando z ya voy a
poder sacar a alguien quién cumple la
propiedad de que está dentro de este
triángulo pues ustedes ya que me gustaba
más fijarme en triángulos vamos a
fijarnos en este tramo de aquí esté aquí
en lugar de fijarnos en cinco triángulos
iguales
solamente voy a fijar esta pequeña parte
de aquí
este triángulo cumple que tiene dos
algunos iguales un ángulo y otra muy
bien y el otro llamado z pero se está
sabemos que vale 72 entonces james más
bien más 72 más 72 la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo me debe
dar 180 grados
ok dicho de otra manera dos veces y debe
de ser igual a 180 menos 72 180 menos 72
y entonces dos veces debe ser igual a
108 y de aquí yo puedo tener valor de 10
podría dividir todo entre 2 y decir que
vale 54 pero realmente lo que me importa
es el valor de 2 bien ya triste cuenta
no importa el valor de dornier porque
cuánto vale este más este este mes
estival en 210 lo cuales 108 grados es
decir que de aquí hasta acá este mundo
de aquí son 101
grados y eso no va a servir para obtener
justo atrás lo que voy el valor de x
porque dos veces más
x suman 180 grados son ángulos
suplementarios dos veces más x tiene que
ser igual a 180 grados porque si te das
cuenta forman un ángulo ya no todo esto
todo esto son 180 grados y eso quiere
decir que son ángulos suplementarios
pero ya sé cuánto vale 22 10 vales 108
entonces 108 más x esto tiene que ser
igual a 180 grados ok el equipo a
obtener que x es igual a 72 grados otra
vez 180 menos 108 es lo mismo que 72 y
es justo lo que quería el valor de x x
vale 72 grados y qué curioso fíjate que
x vale exactamente lo mismo que z sema
es un poco raro eso pero eso nos vamos a
pensar un poco vas a darte cuenta que es
muy cierto x vale lo mismo que se dan
porque dos meses más
es lo mismo que 180 grados cuando este
triángulo de clean y 2 veces x es igual
a 180 grados porque son ángulos
suplementarios y entonces ya tenemos la
respuesta x debe de valer 72 grados y es
el inciso ser la respuesta a este
problema es el inciso sem que me dice
que x son 72 grados de lujo
vamos a resolver el siguiente problema
el problema número 11 el problema número
12 y dice lo siguiente la longitud de un
dibujo de una herramienta es de tres
octavos la longitud de la herramienta
real o que yo me fijo en un dibujo y la
longitud de este dibujo vamos a ponerle
de de dibujo la longitud de este dibujo
es igual a tres octavos de lo que vale
realmente a tres octavos de lo que vale
realmente entonces le voy a poner el
valor real ok si la medida del dibujo de
la herramienta es seis centímetros
cuanto y de la herramienta real ok lo
que me dan es el valor de de la medida
del dibujo de la herramienta son seis
centímetros entonces 6 centímetros es
igual a tres octavos a tres
octavos por efe y yo lo que quiero es el
valor de r
ok qué te parece si la vuelta está rdx y
la voy a poner acá porque voy a
multiplicar todo por el inverso
multiplicativo de tres octavos y el
inverso multiplicativo de tres octavos
es otro tercios
voy a multiplicar todo por ocho tercios
y de aquí también voy a multiplicar todo
por los tres todo lo que esté del lado
izquierdo todo esté del lado derecho de
tal manera que éste y éste se va a ir
este y éste se va a ir y del lado
derecho no queda solamente r mientras
que del lado derecho me va a quedar seis
por ocho tercios lo cual es a éste y
esto puede ir me queda dos y queda uno y
entonces a ocho por dos entre uno es el
mismo que 16 16 centímetros la longitud
de la herramienta real es de 16
centímetros y ya está el problema número
11 está bastante fácil y es el inciso c
del lujo vamos a resolver el problema
número 12 y creo que me cabe aquí dice
si x + 3 entre 2 x + 3 entre 2 es un
entero es entero
ok si x 3 entre dos es entero que no
puedes decir de x wow esto parece este
una pregunta filosófica a ver vámonos
con calma si x + 3 entre 12 se enteró
eso quiere decir que x + 3 es un número
de invisible entre 2 de manera exacta
porque si yo tuviera por ejemplo 11 11
arriba y 2 abajo eso no sería entero
para que esto sea entero forzosamente la
parte de arriba debe de ser parte de
otra manera un número que sea divisible
entre 2 lo de arriba debe ser un número
de dirección entre 2 para que el hacer
la división de que de un número entero y
la única forma de que yo divida algo
entre 2001 el mundo entero eso quiere
decir que ese número debe de ser para
entonces bueno x
3 debe de ser un número par para que x 3
entre 12 entero
ok vamos a ponerlo así esto implica que
x + 3 debe de ser para ahora sí x + 3
debe de ser para que recordemos
recordemos a ver si yo tengo un par y le
sumó un par
esto me daba un número par si yo tengo
un par y le sumó un número impar
esto me da un número impar estás de
acuerdo para más impar me da un par 4
más 13 7 es un número impar ok si yo
tengo un número impar y le suma un
número par pues el mismo que acá arriba
me va a quedar un número impar
ok 3 47 ok y para finalizar siguiente un
número impar ya esto le sumó un número
del par a esto me da un número a 7 más
11 18 ok me da un número par de lujo par
más palpar
palmas sin parar y par en par' más padre
y par en par más sin par
ok pero 33 s si es muy imparte es así lo
conocemos bastante bien este es impar y
par ok si tres es impar si estoy aquí es
impar esto quiere decir que a ya tengo
un impar y para que me dé un par
forzosamente el otro debe de ser impar
impar va sin par
me da par es justo lo que yo quiero que
me dé un número par por lo tanto x x
debe de ser por lo tanto esto implica
que x debe de ser impar
de tal manera que empalma sentarme de
pan por ejemplo si x vale no sé
17 17 + 3 es 2020 es un número par y 20
entre 210 y 10 es un entero de lo vamos
bien y vamos a ver si estamos incisos
noveno en el inciso me dice justo lo que
quiero y me dice que x es impar y es
justo lo que quería
entonces es muy el ciso y del ojo número
11 número 12 vamos a abordar la pantalla
y vamos a ser el problema número 13 el
problema número 13 que me dice lo
siguiente
en el plano cartesiano siguiente q y ese
son los centros de dos círculos que son
tangentes al eje de las x lo que mejor
voy a hacer la gráfica de una vez el
plan que ya no tengo aquí el eje
o qué
tengo aquí el eje x
ok
y vamos a poner que se elegirían este de
ti oh no espera estoy aquí es elegir
este de aquí es el eje x y tengo dos
círculos uno pequeño y uno grande así
que vamos a intentar hacerlos me gusta
este color para el color de círculos
tengo uno que es más o menos así más o
menos así es tangente el eje x se ve más
o menos así ok
este es uno de ellos y el otro es más
grande entonces se ve algo más o menos
así es más grande y se ve más o menos
así tengo otro círculo parecido a éste
de lujo ahora imagínate que este es su
centro este su centro y le voy a poner
el nombre de q este es q y a éste a éste
le voy a poner al centro ese ok y
después tengo dos puntos tengo aquí el
punto p justo por acá está el punto p
punto 36 ok eso dicen y aquí tengo el
punto r por aquí tengo el punto r que es
el punto a 11,10 11,10 11,10 de lujo
si yo bajo una recta desde el pp pasa
por q y llega hasta el eje de asx de
manera perpendicular ok hace un ángulo
recto y de igual manera para r y ese
entonces yo bajo una recta por aquí toca
el eje x y es una recta perpendicular al
eje x ok eso me va a servir bastante que
ingenioso problema me agrada mucho
fíjate bien a que me dice o lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale la pendiente
cuánto vale la pendiente de la recta q s
la recta cuesta y bueno esta es una
recta que sigue sigue sigue
y para acá también sigue sigue y sigue
es una recta más o menos así ok lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale su pendiente
cuánto vale su pendiente bien am pero q
y ese son el centro de cada una de las
circunferencias entonces qué te parece
si sacamos sus coordenadas creo que lo
más fácil es hacer eso porque fíjate
bien este punto este punto p
tiene seis unidades en seis comunidades
en diez y tres en equis y si te das
cuenta el centro está justo abajo de
este punto por lo tanto podemos decir
que q al menos lo que sabemos de primera
mano es que el valor de x de este punto
también vale 3 y podemos decir que
también vale 3 porque este punto está
abajo de este punto
y ahora si nosotros queremos saber cuál
es la distancia en jr pues date cuenta
que la distancia de aquí acá es la mitad
de aquí acá la mitad que de aquí acá si
desde aquí hasta acá hay seis unidades
eso quiere decir que el radio debe de
valer tres el rey debe de valer tres y
por lo tanto la altura de este punto es
también tres en perfecto ya tengo cuánto
vale q vamos a usar la misma lógica para
sacar ese fíjate bien yo sé que esta
altura es 10 aquí estoy para el valor de
10 y aquí estoy en 11 en x por lo tanto
ese debe tener en x como coordenada 11
porque porque estamos justo abajo de er
ahora sí pensamos en este valor que
nosotros necesitamos para james date
cuenta que el diámetro de este círculo
es 10 por lo tanto el radio 5 y 5 lo que
quiere decir que la altura del punto s
debe de ser sin
de lujo ahora sí sí ya tengo dos puntos
ya puedo sacar la pendiente entre esos
dos puntos recuerda queda pendiente es
lo mismo que el cambio en 10 con
respecto al cambio en x así que vamos a
tomarnos el cambio en jr
voy a empezar en este punto así que me
voy a tomar 5 menos 35 menos 3 entre a
ahora me voy a tomar el cambio en x 11
menos 3 y ojo siempre se en este punto
me voy a tomar a éste como un segundo
punto 11 menos 3 y esto va a ser igual a
5 menos 32 am 11 menos 3 es 8 y esto lo
mismo que un cuarto es decir que la
pendiente de esta recta demorado y es
más lo voy a poner con morado la
pendiente de la recta de morado es un
cuarto que es justo lo que quería la
pendiente de esta recta la pendiente es
un cuarto y te lujo lo saqué con dos
puntos y por cierto es el inciso b
la respuesta a este problema es el
inciso b así que hemos acabado el tiempo
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo